もう連ブリーダー
この夏あ
を頑張ってああ
南海徹夜したがー
8月ねー
ご解説痩せるじゃない
忙しかったあーーあわー俺も寝るの格子んでいろんなことして
まぁ時々はそんな結局急がすけどあー
そんな8月道路
唯一の楽しみはああ
ポケモンゴーぞ
裂空斬を捕まえるほど
なんか
見たんですけど何
5%の確率20体捕まえるとそのうち1匹は確率的に黒いね kooza が出るって
言ってんだけど
dane
ああああああ
どうしてだ
わー
誰が
おはすやでぐらい
ああああああ
うわあああああ
わー
8月1日からずっとやっててなんかイベントやっているかといいますと
69回ほんなら絶対なあー
[音楽]
ああ
わーい
わー
なんでてるんだよ70階は立ってるんだぞ
ウォッチャーハーバーんがぁ
ならぁぁ
ran はから nao
それだわー
コバぜたーーー
以前正義捕まっちゃな絶対寝るって言ってるじゃ誰
話がついじゃねーかぁ70匹捕まえて0って
0%だエーカー
up 1ナイスてっぺんだ俺が1回かぁ
時間ない時で頑張ってやってダメでしたーー
わー
た付けてくださ
僕はあ
[音楽]
ねクーガー
土田もようなんですよべ用ラインであるがー
bani
ああああああああ
[音楽]
こっち画像らー
ふああああああ
うわあああああ
ああああああああ
うううううかぜ俺の方てるぞ
概してりゃー
あーなどれが答えできる動画を出してるかっていうと理由があるそう
今日8月1日はメイザー
18時から19時はレッグ歌しか出ない日だった
俺はそんな羊がー本気で食うぞ
楽しま keter
もちろん俺たちのじゃないわー
強いねクズじゃない
beck 頭が遅いわけでもない
俺たちが求めていたら
chloe クザ
ただいびき
jr タンやっほわぁ
1なんからあああ
んじゃあ
パワーねえぞとかにゃ1時間の無駄じゃなんだったんだよああ
もう時間がねぇんだよこの一事がで作られなかったら
もう俺だぜ時間はねえ
8月2日までスパショもやってるけど
そんなには者
ねえさあ
ああああああああ
暗い子と出会えジャガー
だぜぇ
ああああああああああああ
ハダ連絡ガメラ
ああああああああ
earth
緑でもいいじゃないですか
べっカイザー
ピザです
ミドルもいいじゃないですか
うよ枝トーン
フェ取りラガーん
ぺどりあぼんなら絶対論点だ
入らないミドルでもいいじゃないですか
乱れやトーン
いや何だよああ
[音楽]
を出てないんすよちゅらねーなーんで出てくんじゃないですか俺がし later
俺後ててぇんだよああ
なんで今出てくるんですかおまえもリーダー
なんでねーどだけじゃないですか俺が知るじゃ俺は俺は出なかったんやー
ああああああああ
うわぁ
[音楽]